[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael rosenbom thank you for being
here and choosing this show as your show
for the week I'm sure you have other
things to listen to and do in your life
but you've decided to stay with me for
this for this 50 minutes for this hour
it's nothing you could do it uh Ryan
welcome hi good to see you good to see
you too how you doing nice to see you
you had a surprise party for your dad
for his birthday for his uh 70th I did
yeah he was really surprised that's
sweet that's what the surprise part is
for I told you i' never had a surprise
party uh I know have you is that you
saying that you want a surprise party
well no but no one's ever thr me on I've
always been a part of everyone else's
surprise party I don't think you can ask
for a surprise party I'm
not anyway um thank you for listening I
I ask you if you like the podcast if
you're really enjoying it just subscribe
it really helps the podcast and uh write
a review it really works with the
algorithms and gets the show more
popular um and if you want to give back
to the podcast our patrons save the show
they really do they are unbelievable
thank you all patrons patreon p a o n
patreon.com inside of you also the
inside of you online uh store has uh
smvo scripts and ship Keys autographs
all that stuff go to the inside you
online store I'm on the Cameo all that
you go to sunspin decom for any Bann
information or um anything you want to
buy there or buy a zoom with me and Rob
um and on my link tree and my bio at the
Michel Rosen moment Instagram you can
find all this stuff so just go there um
I am going to say a few things before we
get into this incredible interview um
with an incredible Guy this is uh I
became very friendly I worked with him
incredible to work with very giving as
an actor and sitting down with him and
talking to him um he's just he's very
open and he's he's old school in terms
of he says what he wants to say what he
believes he you know doesn't [__]
you and uh I really enjoyed having
Vincent denafo Legend if you ask me he's
done so much incredible work and we talk
a lot about it and we'll get into that
first I want to read something for you
uh also go to Monster paloa in Pasadena
October 13th 14th Weekend Monster paloa
it's like horror stuff it's totally cool
if you like horr but go get a ticket to
that it's awesome I'm going guys and
don't forget please come support inside
of you with Michael Ros mom live at the
Regent Theater downtown Los Angeles 8:00
pm October 11th my special guest is Zach
Levi Zach freak and Levi Shazam chuck
all that goodness uh we're really
excited um it's going to be a great
night it's my first live show so I hope
people show up so get a ticket and and
come see me it's going to be a great
night I also want to say that October is
domestic violence awareness month did
you know that 10 million women and men
are physically abused by an intimate
partner in the US every year for over 50
years the takeback the night Foundation
has been working to eradicate Domestic
and Sexual Violence in all forms this
month I'm partnering with takeback the
night to spread the word and help raise
much needed funds for them to continue
their good work on campuses all across
the country and in their Global Outreach
programs please click the link you can
go take backthe night.org for more
information and donate and help for a
good cause together we can shatter the
silence together we can take back the
night all right so just a few important
things and I also want to say I'm
incredibly proud of my friend Shir ASO
and the animal rescue mission for all
the work they're doing and saving so
many animals um it's an amazing
nonprofit that I just adore I'm on the
board and they do they work wonders
they're magical I wish everybody had as
big hearts as they do and uh yeah animal
rescue mission folks it's uh it's
awesome all right without further Ado
let's get into it let's get inside of
Vincent denafo it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen
[Music]
bomb inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience hey folks wanted to
highlight something important before
today's episode in case you weren't
aware myself and many of the guests are
on strike alongside sag after and wga
today's episode in any we a before the
strike ends were recorded before it
began so this is just a heads up in
relation to some for the topics we may
discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit Saga strike. org now let's
get into
it I'm I'm so excited by by the way you
really look good I'm like holy [__] you
look just chiseled you lost weight and
you've been working the [__] out haven't
you well I'm try we're trying we're
doing this particular thing yeah yeah
I'm I'm training hard yeah does it rhyme
with Fair feville no not at all you just
can't talk about that at all can
you um
no no you just can't like the only thing
I can say is that it's a a different
show
and um you know that's it I mean it's
really it's like car it's terrible it's
like that's the way things are these
days you can't uh can't discuss anything
and then everything I do say even if
it's something very subtle people look
into it the wrong way and then it
becomes this kind of news thing and then
and then it seems like um to the rest of
the the cast and stuff that I'm out
there talking about the show when I'm
actually not so right you don't go to a
lot of cons huh I you know I had a
change of um feeling about them a couple
of years ago you know I
I I don't I didn't like participating in
much
you than showing up on time at work and
uh you know but I have to say
though you know it's you make a little
bit of
money and it's
extraordinary I had this thing happen
where I know this is probably very
typical you probably happened to you a
million times but it never happened to
me before where a woman came up and it's
a very simple thing she said that her
her dad was ill he was in the hospital
and that he's been a huge fan of mine
his whole life and um we were about the
same age and
uh um you know and and I asked her if I
don't know it just hit me heavy and I
asked her if she would you know you're
not supposed to hold up the line I asked
her if I if she wanted to FaceTime him
so she did and I won't tell you what he
said specifically but he said some very
intense stuff to me about his health and
about um his welfare and and uh a
particular thing
about just this little in
insignificant part that I played in
uh um Adventures in Babysitting I played
Thor wow at the end
right yeah like I helped them with their
car yeah and then I give girl my uh my
winged helmet you know right right that
I kind of pull out oh no she gives her
she's dressed as Thor and she gives me
her winged helmet sorry and uh because
she believes that I'm Thor and I'm kind
of actually in the adventures of
babysitting world am I am Thor and so uh
at least that's what I
believed anyway so he he you know there
was this little story that he told me
about that and
about um how
men uh have trouble with their
questioning their integrity all through
life you know and how a lot of men
suffer from worthlessness even if they
never admit it and you know women women
do too obviously um but this particular
story was about
men and uh that for some
reason that hit him that I would come
off of Full Metal Jacket and play that
little part in that movie and look
completely different and like he found
that to be truly
inspiring it I
mean how that kind of thing happens is
beyond me
but
um so like that's I've never ever been
in that position you know I I sign
autographs all the time I don't I don't
shy away from that if people want
pictures I do that I've done that my
whole career I learned from Gregory
Hines um a very good lesson about that
yeah so I'll tell you what Greg taught
me in a minute but but it was um you
know so I've always I've never Shi away
from that kind of stuff but I've
never because I do more um television
and films than I do theater you know um
like in three quarters of my career is
all theater I mean it's all films and
television and very few plays and um so
I don't get that kind of thing you know
I don't get to hear what people think of
these little parts that I've played and
I've done a million of them because I
always thought I always I don't care
like how big the part is I'll go play it
if I like it if I help anything to I
know this sounds corny but you know
anything to help service the story
honestly that's really how I feel about
it and whether it's an hour or a lead or
or supporting role like I do mostly
these days and or if it's a part that
lasts two minutes in a movie I I love
that stuff and you know nobody ever
keeps me from bringing in a full
character you know like even if it's for
two minutes nobody has say nobody says
like oh you're you know like you just
got to come in and say toine like like
I'm allowed to do whatever I want which
I'm very fortunate you know I think that
stems from theater because when we're
when I'm doing plays I remember back
it's sort of like this thing where yeah
you do this little part and you play
this you put a hat on you put a mustache
you put like it's like what we love to
do and so you want to just you don't
want to be just like this you want to
kind of do a lot of different fun things
exactly yeah exactly that and so ever
since then I've had a completely
different view about the Comic Cons and
so so now I have a person that helps me
with them and and I go whenever whenever
I can you know whenever it's not get
doesn't get in the way of my life and
and my job but I go but but but before
that you know was I didn't participate
because I
felt a little shy about it and also I
mean shy in the way like just personally
shy about it and I also felt
um like um I wasn't like people weren't
interested in in my career in that way
but it turns out that all those little
parts that I played and I guess they
bigger ones too people have it it have
has affected people's lives and that's
just so sweet that you can't I mean
that's just so sweet to me I feel the
same way and um you know the impact that
we don't even realize that we have on
people and you do a role that you feel
oh that's insignificant like no nobody
might have even seen there's movies that
I've done that I you know do I wish I
never have did yeah maybe but uh they
come and they bring something to sign
I'm like oh my you saw this you were the
one who saw this movie and like yeah
yeah my dad and I we love this there's a
connection and hearing them talk to you
about their connection and your
connection it just it it it just feels
good and you know before you know a long
time ago people would say oh you know
you're just taking fans money and I'm
like let me tell you something okay
because I thought about it in the
beginning and I I came up to the
conclusion that you know like I might
want to go to Hawaii for
vacation these guys that go and I used
to go to conventions by myself before I
became anybody I was going to horror
movie conventions with my dork friends
and like you know we didn't have any
money getting like some guy from Dawn of
the Dead to sign our a picture for five
bucks or whatever but this is their
vacation whether they cplay or they come
for the weekend and they're with their
friends get a hotel definitely into it
they want yeah they're loving this don't
feel bad for these these fans or are you
kidding me they're so happy I envy them
I envy the fun they have well yeah I
mean there is no bad feelings at these
things yeah there is you run into next
to no negativity like that is a rare
place for entertainers to be yes yeah
and we are very lucky to be in those
people's company well you also were
talking about a minute ago you tapped
into it you're like you know I was I'm
kind of shy and but you've been dealing
with shyness since you were young right
yeah yeah I mean you I I read that you
like you know you're always in your head
you'd be up in your room I believe it or
not people look at me as an extrovert
and then I read somewhere where just
because you do outlandish things and
you're like funny and and you're it
doesn't mean you're not an introvert and
I still have an anxiety with people
believe it or not and I used to go to my
room up for the for the weekends I never
went to a dance I never went to high
school anything and I used to borrow my
parents VCR put it to my VCR and copy
movies and just watch old movies and
just sit up there and I didn't have a
lot of friends and I was the smallest
kid so I understand that what were you
what did were you popular in score were
you just kind of did you feel like you
were an outcast no no nobody nobody knew
me in
school nobody knew me
nobody I very few people I had I had a
good friend ELO Medina Cuban kid because
like I went to school I went to Junior
High uh most of elementary junior high
and High School in in h of
Florida and and uh so my I had a few
friends on the Block but they were
pretty nasty
people um pretty tough characters and
uh uh but my my best buddy was Ellie M
we ended up traveling across country uh
together in a Toyota Corolla I believe
um right after high school perfect we
went from M from Florida from hiia to
San
Francisco but um no no I I don't I
didn't go to my prom I
didn't I think I'm in I think maybe
there's one picture of me in a yearbook
my you know my hair is like down to here
it's super
curly chubby little kid you know
like like some kind of like generic
motorcycle shirt not even like a brand
just a motorcycle like some kind of
cartoon it's funny it's funny because I
picture you I have this image because
you know you play tough guys and Sero
killers and all these different things I
mean obviously you play a lot of
different stuff but I always you know
until I met you and we ended up doing a
a dax's movie we had a scene that was
cut out in the beginning where I was
like oh my God this guy's [__] he's
hilarious he's engaging he's like you
know he gives and takes and just he's a
listener and it's I just was like Amazed
by how uh how cool you were and I but I
had this
image Vincent denafo is probably the guy
in that movie um My Bodyguard with Matt
Dylan and Adam Baldwin Adam Baldwin and
he's probably that guy who's kind of a
loner Outcast wearing that jacket but
can kick ass if he has to were you that
guy or not as cool I was not cool at all
but I did learn fairly quickly how to
defend myself because there was a lot of
nasty stuff going on in the neighborhood
and so um but that was just sheer and
also you know I felt obligated to
protect my older sisters for some reason
and and so like you know and then so but
the group that I hung out
with um were definitely troublemakers
you know so I had to avoid most of it I
mean I was I was causing a lot of
trouble my the guy who saved my ass was
U my stepdad he was a firefighter when
he came into our lives he basically got
me off the street like he
basically did some things that my
sisters and my mom don't even never even
knew about like um to help me out um
straighten me out a little bit
so um yeah like it no but yeah no I can
be you know you know da and I are very
similar in that way like
we we're idiots when it comes to um
fighting and stuff like we we don't
think
like it like you the best fighters are
the ones that are not afraid of being
hurt you know like that's the main thing
yeah you know Dex is very much like that
and I I think that him and I are are
similar in that way you know obviously
we've we've grown up but we you
know for a significant amount of years
now but um so that's a lot of that is I
guess all of that is behind us now
because of our children and our
relationships and stuff
but inad is brought to you by prize
piics um I don't know about you but I
like to have some fun and I like to have
some fun with my money and I don't like
to always spend a lot of money but
sometimes everybody's playing this
fantasy thing well prize pick is the
largest independently owned daily
fantasy sports platform in North America
easiest most exciting way to play daily
fantasy sports period and I'm telling
you because I have the app I put money
in the app and I am doing it it's so
great because when I'm watching football
you don't even really need to know
anything you could do a little research
if you want but you know it shows you
two quarterbacks playing each other
you're like okay you just select both of
them right and then it says are they
going to get more than 200 pass yards or
less than 200 pass yards you put oh more
less and for 20 bucks you you win 60 or
however much you put in you get a lot
more it's so easy it's so fun
everybody's always playing these these
daily fantasy things or these weekly
things with their friends and it's so
timec consuming this isn't this is
really fun it's it's the most fun I've
had winning up to 25 times my money this
football season you just select as I
said two or more players pick more or
less on their projected stats place your
entry testing my skills and prize picks
this football season is the most
exciting way to play daily fantasy
sports if you have the skills you can
turn $10 into 250 with just a few Taps
Ryan yep uh I'm doing it I'm having fun
have you won I'm having fun with it I'll
say that much all right he doesn't want
to talk about his money well I bet he's
won a lot I could see the smile on his
face um look quick withdrawals easy
gameplay an enormous selection of
players and Stat types are what make
prize pick the number one daily fantasy
sports app prize pick offers weekly
promotions that can lead to Big payouts
like taco Tuesday each Tuesday price
picks discount select player projections
up to 25% to provide even more value
prize pick now offers Apple pay for
quick and easy deposits into your
account this football season with prize
pick reboot policy your entri stay in
play even if one of your players gets
injured for pro football games and
college football top 20 25 matchups if
you have a player who exits the game in
the first half and does not return in
the second that player is rebooted prize
picks is the only Deli fantasy sports
platform with injury Insurance we're
having such a ball with this I think you
should too it's a lot a lot of fun go to
priz picks.com
inside and use code inside for a first
deposit matchup $
$100 yeah go to prize.com
inside and use code inside for a first
deposit matchup to
$100 must be present in certain States
visit prize.com for restrictions and
details this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so your brain can work for you
instead of against you and this is what
happens with um therapy you're you have
all these things bottled up and you need
to let them out and you need to talk to
a professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapists anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like no
I want to try someone else it's easy
just like that better help is truly the
best way to make your brain your friend
give it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com
SL
inside you could tell that you bring
that intensity like you say you've grown
up you you're married you've got your
life you don't put yourselves in the in
put yourself in that situation but there
is that side of you that brings out the
best in your performances sometimes that
I see that sort of angst that sort of
like dark side and do you think that
comes from those early days of childhood
do you think that um do you still have
those
I think my I
don't like my good friends that are
actors the like they're they think I'm a
little mentally deficient because I
don't get nervous and so like I don't
get I I don't get butterflies I think
that comes from my childhood but the the
stuff during performances I mean that's
a [__] that I'm Conjuring up from my my
life for sure but I'm not it's not
something it's something that I have to
bring forward again and and speak
through it you know that's that's the
way that I studied acting that's the way
I was taught how to act you know so it's
that's what I do when I when I do that
kind of stuff that's all
about U bringing up events and speaking
the author's words through those events
yeah do you get upset with yourself do
you uh when you're not where you want to
be in a scene how do you channel that
does that make you nervous are you
thinking about oh I'm letting people
down are you just like I'm just going to
I'm me like you say you don't get
nervous so you don't get even First Day
Jitters uh what how do you uh if you're
not getting through a scene if you're
not feeling it how do you do that how do
you work through it you
fail you just fail and that's [__]
great I love that that that's I mean I
know this
sounds um it's it's a little awkward to
be talking about because
you know I'm not trying to come across
as some kind of like dude that's
impenetrable you know I'm definitely you
know
um I'm definitely have been humbled many
times in my life and still carry a lot
of humility around with me from those
events
of when I was extremely humbled but um
no no I I don't I I if I I believe that
if you're not putting your head out on
the chopping block every time you walk
out on stage or every time they say the
camera is rolling then you're not you're
not doing the best you can you you have
to fail I fail constantly every day wow
when I'm working and and I do not get
nervous about it no that is [__] epic
I wish that I could have that that
feeling I have been moments where I'm so
confident you could throw anything at me
and I'm impenetrable and then there's
moments where I'm a little [__] boy
and I feel like my dad's yelling at me
and I'm embarrassing myself and both
those feelings are so extremes that I I
don't you know I strive for the
Excellence but sometimes
you you don't fail on purpose but you
sometimes you know I I was talking to
you at a con and I said something to you
and you kind of laugh you told me this
little story um when you were doing Law
and Order Criminal Intent now the first
time I saw that I had never seen Law and
Order and I was on the TV and I stopped
because I like you and I started
watching you and I
go what what is he doing what I found
myself I don't know what happened so
captivated in the way you were
delivering [__] and the way you were
just your manners it was like it was
like you putting it together like a real
person but so quirky and like you know
that you would do these things where
you're like and the the left hand what
I'm just trying you were like I could
see you thinking the character thinking
like it was real and and I go did they
like what you were doing right away in
the dailies in the beginning and you
were like no can you elaborate on
that well no they didn't like it at all
I mean they worried about it yeah I
there was I don't know which story I
told you but you know I would save
certain spots to pause in and not speak
and that that drove them crazy because
you know but I you know I was like this
is not radio like you can stop talking
like it's okay to stop talking and by
the way you could cut it out if you want
you know but um there was
a it was until Dick Wolf got it like he
got it that that um people were
into that weirdness that the idea that I
had the guts enough to just pause and
not speak for a moment um while that the
room is full of actors and the camera is
rolling um he he thought that that was
exciting and and he he they he he was
the one that gave me permission to do
all of that stuff that I was trying to
do and um because I used to block um
those Arya scenes were saved for me to
block like I would block them and I I
never changed the word once the script
was I I gave some notes but very rarely
we had great writers on that show you
know like great writers yeah and um but
uh you know for that kind of thing
they're they're brilliant you know they
were brilliant and
um but but I I wouldn't change a word
but I would block the scene I would
block the scene myself like because I
had it all in my mind of how exactly the
whole thing unfolds and some of those P
some of those scenes were 12 to 15 pages
long you know and so of just straight do
we used to do them top to bottom like
like a piece of theat like we wouldn't
stop and then do lines like we would do
it top to bottom so if you were so that
sometimes there'd be like three
sometimes there' be five people in those
scenes coming in and out of the room and
stuff like that it was fantastic was a
Fant and Kate Herby who plays my partner
was from Stephen wolf I mean she was so
ready to to give me lessons in that kind
of work you know like amazing
so so yeah that that it made them
nervous at first but you know once they
once the companies like that start
making money their nerves go away you
know yeah absolutely yeah I just I just
I find that fascinating but also the
first thing that I come that comes to
mind my listeners will know this is how
do you learn all those pages of dialogue
every day you're working constantly Law
and Order you're not doing like Eight
Episodes a year on a streaming show you
were doing how many episodes 22 to 23
how did you I know I mean how how did
you deal with that well I would stay
three scripts ahead it's is I I only had
one choice I can only do that there's
the only way so so I was giving notes on
one script that I had just
read um the other script uh the the
second script I would be um trying to
figure out how I could actually what how
to control my arc in it and then the
third one would be the one that we were
performing at the time and I was
learning and I was learning
scenes I would stay two days ahead of
scenes and still be studying while I'm
performing other scenes so it was like a
lot of work you know yeah because you
had a you had exhaustion you collapsed
on set like in 2004 right yeah I mean
did you know that this did you feel like
this is going to happen like my body
can't take this anymore I'm so [__]
tired did you feel it or did it just
happen how did what
happened
um I just couldn't believe that we were
working so much I just couldn't believe
that that it was okay to do year after
year and um you know I learned the hard
way that it was okay that that's the way
the business was and it's not like that
anymore the New York Times did an
article about the hours the tele
television hours and Kate and I were you
know a main part of that that article
like because we were at the time
averaging 16 17 hours a
day and that that that you know that
they said that in that article like so
it's
like um but you know it's like today
these days it's like a [__]
vacation I mean honestly nine ep nine
episodes a season yeah you
know you know granted in in network
television you make tons more money but
in the end it ain't worth it yeah that's
the thing I mean you do sell your soul
in a way you're like you're risking your
health nasty you get nasty I
was I was you know I got to the point
where I was
completely um in my head and and and
just had no patience for for anything
anything you know like the only people
that I would give back to were the other
actors and and and the camera crew
everybody else to me was just in my way
and taking up my time from getting home
and going to sleep wow yeah did they
ever have a conversation with
but I have to say though having said all
that when I left that show I was 10
times a better actor than I was before I
went on it
wow what why is that why is that is it
the intensity and all that combined just
my chops got so good like I was just my
chops I I learned how to transition so
much easier you know I was just used to
doing film where you you do story
transition transitions or emotional
transitions over like three scenes or an
act
you know but on television you do
transitions within a scene you know big
ones yeah and so to be able to pull that
off was you know it I I think it does
with everybody it it it you either it
either makes you or breaks you and you
either end up um coming in and doing one
line cut one line cut one line cut which
a lot of people end up doing or you
master it and you become this like
machine yeah everybody does obviously
not just me and um and you leave at some
a situation like that like you know
you're
you're you're great at at the technical
aspect of your job yeah there's nothing
better than getting something from a job
like when you leave
saying wow I I I'm better like like you
said I'm better now all the hard work
all the [__] the exhaustion the whatever
the in my head pissed off whatever it
was all that prepares you for maybe
something that you're not even aware of
yeah I was sent this
um footage from a film I did in
Australia when I was younger I think it
was like my fifth film or something was
called was with Rucker Howard Joan Chan
and myself
called I think in austral we shot it in
Australia it was called salute of the
Jugger it was like a it was around Mad
Max time it was like
around the third Mad Max time like in
that area and uh it was like a post-apoc
post-apocalyptic movie about a team
called that played this sport fictitious
sport called Jugger and we went around
in this post-apocalyptic
environment walking through the desert
from from Stadium to Stadium playing
this game wow and anyway I recently saw
an interview that was done on set this
is is before Law and Order this is like
early on in my
career and I was like what a [__]
prick this [__] kid is oh
my how did anybody like honestly it's
like how could anybody sit next to this
[__] jerk off like oh my God in this
interview I was like I don't know what
the [__] was going on in my head I was
like a penis with arms and
[Laughter]
legs no [__] brain
just erect and
ready just like stupid like so stupid
I've done that I've been there I know
what you're saying so stupid and so like
you know embarrassing oh my god well
that's all right we do of course it's
all right but it's like unbelievable to
watch it you see yourself and it's
literally like different person yeah you
know I wasn't going to ask you about
this because you've answered every
question people have talked to you about
it ad nauseum so I but i' do myself an
injustice if I didn't bring up something
about it but like playing and and you
could tell me if you even like talking
about it but playing private Leonard
Lawrence in Full Metal Jacket um I'm
sure you've been asked everything my
only real question really is it's so
intense those moments and I just was was
any of that improvised was any of what
he was saying improvised he wasn't even
an actor right what's his name I'm sorry
Lee Lee hery Lee hery who was brilliant
in everything I'd seen him so what would
happen was he you know he did he was a
drill instructor in real in real life
you know for for many years after you
know this guy did three tours in Vietnam
he went back
twice he volunteered to go back twice
that's a stud um so he was there you
know like for all the [__] he was in the
[__] for many years over there and you
know you know showed us his bullet holes
and everything and honestly like the
real deal and um
but he so he had an abundance uh from
being a drill instructor and being
around in that life his whole life in
that world his whole life he had
abundance of things to say but Stanley
so he would he would just say them spurt
them out Stanley would then type them
all out word for word but then Lee would
have to then do them every time so he
kind of dug his own grave because he was
sort of at the time just barely an actor
and uh not not to rate his ability
because his ability was amazing but he
had just you know he was green still in
my mind he was green still even as a
young man I was like this guy this guy's
green you know and um but uh and that
was my first film so like I didn't know
any different but no there was no
improvising but you know so in a way he
was spitting out improvisations but not
when the camera was rolling yeah it's
almost like you know um because I
remember watching the documentary on The
Shining and like you know Stanley's
always typing in his little typewriter
yeah and you know Jack would say
something you know Little Pigs Little
Pigs and then he'd be
like he's like adding stuff um really
yeah yeah was he intense with you did he
want did he was he intense as a director
because he wanted you to feel that or
not at all no he spoke very little
didn't talk about story didn't talk
about acting didn't talk about the scene
never nothing ever ever ever how many
takes the most I did was nine and that
was for the blanket party when they put
the soap in the towels and beat me up we
did nine of those the big scene the big
famous
scene um they say the big famous scene
anyway it's it's uh um you know when I
killed the drill instructor and I shoot
myself that that we did three times you
know and then we did a an effect for the
blood in the wall and that was it what I
mean all you hear is 100 takes 90 takes
50 doors I'm not saying he didn't do
that with other people but not with us
not with Matthew and I and um and Arles
like we
never Matthew Matthew Arles and and in
their team when they were doing the
Vietnam stuff they got stuck behind that
wall there's a wall that they're behind
before they go into the village right at
the end when the sniper gets right at
the end of the first act when the sniper
uh second act when the sniper gets
killed remember all those guys get shot
in that one little are they were behind
that wall for I believe around four
months
so and it was merely because of the way
Stanley made movies you know he was very
different than anybody I've ever worked
with before you know he if he if the
light wasn't right if the if if the if
the scene was flat he he wouldn't shoot
he just wouldn't shoot did you ever see
him angry not like like you mean like
screaming and yelling and stuff no
because you see it again in The Shining
in the documentary you see it damn it
shell you knew it was there oh come on
yeah well they had a particular relation
yeah some people say it was deliberate
on his behalf because he wanted her to
you know I don't know if that's true I
don't know what it was but it was pretty
you know pretty devastating for
everybody as so I hear and um no it
wasn't but for me it wasn't like I
wasn't there for a lot of the Vietnam
stuff I was only there for the you know
I was there I was there in England for
it but I wasn't on set I only went on
set a couple of times I did I won't say
who but I did experience he came in he
he let me sit next to him I was learning
when they were shooting the Vietnam
stuff they shot that first I was
learning monkey Patrol and marching
monkey Patrol with the rifles you know
the spinning and then the marching and I
was putting on the weight and um
learning all the how to take rifles
apart I was doing all that sort of like
a pseudo boot camp but without the boot
you know right and and uh there was one
day in particular I remember where um
just because I was you know Stanley
Cooper and I wanted to see him direct
you know because I'd seen all his movies
and um he came he he let me sit next to
him during this one particular scene and
he had a megaphone they were like
everybody was like about 50 feet away
and they did 72 takes and this one
particular actor did 72 takes how was
the actor every take you know Stanley
would say like Stanley had this thing
where he would clear his throat he' go
before he would speak every time
and so over the megaphone you'd hear
like um it's uh take 69 uh so and so
um let's try let's just try to get it
better
click like what is the
actor I mean what are you thinking
you're like you're you're beyond
embarrassed at this point you're beyond
like I don't is it me is it like I mean
did you see some ACT did you when you
were on set did you see any of the
actors like that like falling apart like
falling apart is big word I mean not
happy I mean you know not happy you know
nobody's happy in those kind of
circumstance everybody wants to get the
day done and I think that I I I think
that was about a two-day period they
stayed on that one particular actor
until he got it right in Stanley's eyes
you know did you ever um talk to Stanley
again was it at the premiere did he come
up to a couple times on the phone there
was no Premiere not that I know I mean I
certainly didn't but I don't do that
kind of thing but it's um especially
when I was younger I didn't do it these
days I've gotten try I try to be more
civilized about
it but when I was a kid there was nobody
pushing me to do that kind of stuff so I
just didn't do it you know but but he um
no we talked a few times on the phone um
but nothing we weren't like I didn't we
I wasn't like best friends with him or
anything I know a lot of people say that
they were but but I I definitely wasn't
he he helped me tremendously by just
trusting me so much like he gave me One
Direction the whole time I was there and
it was a brilliant Direction and I was
very lucky that we were on the same page
like I was extreme it was like a it was
like
Christmas told the story a million times
oh you have okay I don't want to tell if
you told a million times but he gave you
a direction that changed everything
before that big night he gave me an
incredible Direction before we shot it
the next day um and it and and it just
so happened that that you know luckily I
was thinking along the same lines and so
I went in the next day and we just did
three takes and it was done how many um
how many times have you been on a set
where you're just like I don't like the
director or I don't like the actor I'm
working with and is that really
difficult do you have to sort of suck it
up or do you let it is impossible for
you not to just say to show your colors
like it's [__] stupid I'm not [__]
doing it I'm I mean you know because
I've worked with some directors that I
mean I I almost got in a fist fight with
I've told that story where I just
charged him and uh but I was I was
actually actually right in the moment
and everybody knew it he was just
absolutely belittling and degrading and
poting me it was it was the worst thing
ever and I just have never felt like
that and somebody just in the middle of
it like right before the and the
camera's rolling ad goes hey hey just uh
just Let's do let's talk after this yeah
and the Crane's coming down and the girl
I'm with her like she are you okay I'm
like no and on act the camera's already
coming in we're talking and I just
beelined and they grabbed me and I was
like you don't [__] ever talk to
anybody like that again and it was just
like oh my God I couldn't even I I was
scared because I never do that you know
it's hard to put yourself in any
circumstance it's life it's hard to put
yourself in a servient position if you
don't
respect the person that's a very
difficult thing to do and I need to be
in that position I as an actor I need to
serve the story like I want to serve the
day like that's I feel like that's my
job you know that's why I get paid you
know to service the story and so I need
to truly be put in I need to put myself
in that position you know put me in my
place because you're so [__] amazing
and talented like that's what I need and
um it's very very disappointing when
that doesn't happen it's very
disappointed because you feel lost you
know and then you have to start taking
over and it's not your job to take over
and that's a terrible position to be in
but you know I find that the men and
women that I've worked with
um the ones that are born directors
they're just can't imagine them doing
anything else you know they they you
know they never make you feel like that
they never make you feel like they don't
have the the the they're not steering
the ship so to speak you know and right
and then you feel totally like part of
the crew and like okay let's go I'm with
you 100% you know and then you I show up
in the morning I'm always on time I'm
always [__] prepared and um I mean
we've worked together you know what I'm
like I'm open and yeah ready and and you
know whatever you guys want to do is
okay with me you know but um and I'm a
bit of a smartass at the same time so
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah but you know
so it's like uh you
know hey what you see is what you get
like I have to say that
um when I was a young when I was younger
I had a lot less tolerance about this
situation that I'm talking about about
not feeling like I'm in the right
position that the that the that the
people that I'm supposed to
be that are supposed to be in charge are
not do are not talented and that's
uh that when I was a kid that used to
make me I I used to get worried and I
would I would start to try to take over
and I would you know I would just take
over and and but I don't you know
luckily um my career has gone is is very
much under my own control and there's
been good things about that and bad
things about it but it is under my own
control yeah and and so I put myself in
situations um 99.9% of the time where
I'm working with extremely talented
people and I haven't felt lost in a long
time now when it comes to television
it's different because in television
director is not doesn't have the same
position right as it does in the movie
like it's a completely different thing
so you get used to their
being 5050 there's some amazingly
talented ones and there's some people
that are just there recording the day
you know and that's not very inspiring
but what the [__] do you ever uh have
you ever been piss because I I you're
such a pro you always know you're lines
you like once you walk on set
everything's behind you this is you know
you have everything under control like
you said have you had actors where
you're working with them and they don't
know their [__] lines and it's
throwing you off and it's really pissing
you off and you said learn your [__]
lines I've taken some actors for walks
yeah I'm glad you didn't take me for a
walk yeah I'm very nice about it but
I've I've given um like lessons were
given to me when I was younger in
theater um I I I I'm I can I can give a
lesson I'll give a lesson out every once
in a while
rightfully so what would you say besides
TV work and obviously it was incredibly
difficult but what's the one role that
you can recall in your career that was
the hardest on you physically mentally
the hardest part to play and then the
most
[Music]
rewarding the rewarding part could be a
different role yeah they're they're all
different that way though like for
instance Law and Order was so rewarding
because I was a better actor at the end
of it but with definitely not worth the
money you know the the the trouble it it
the pressure it put on my family and the
pressure it put on me and it was
definitely not worth the money and so I
don't feel the only reward I got from
that was I was a better actor which is a
pretty good reward yeah you know um the
full metal jacket was will always be my
favorite experience because it was my
first experience you know in in a in a
real film you know like a with the with
a top director like if not one of the
best in the world ever yeah um I have to
say the part that I'm playing now that I
started on Netflix the Daredevil show is
um it's a he's a crazy [__] this
guy like he's so like real and emotional
and he's like a big baby and a [__]
monster at the same time and it's very
you know we have on the Netflix show as
well we had the opportunity to put him
in somewhat normal situations he fell he
fell in love he got married um in in in
the in the new stuff we're doing he's in
normal situations as well so the play
even in Hawkeye and and in in Hawkeye
not so much but in Ekko and then which
is not out yet which precedes the new
Daredevil born again show the we he's in
positions in um where like he was in
Netflix where he's the same guy but he's
in a very normal position and to play
him in a normal position like in a
normal environment like you or I would
be in is just batshit [__] crazy it's
like so [__] hard to do and so
[__] crazy and the [__] that's going
on in my mind when the camera is rolling
is just [__] batshit stuff like
honestly like I've I've get to the point
where I cannot wait to see this man do
you do you like when you're rehearsing
it do you rehearse it in a room where
there's nobody else and just kind of
lash out do you have somebody you read
the scenes with and really give it all
or are you just quiet about it and do
your own thing and then and figure it
out on
set I no I I I have a plan and then most
that plan goes out the window this is
very normal right this always happens
with the actors just you know and so but
I have a huge I always have a big plan
coming in and and I don't push it on
anybody if I feel like the blocking is
throwing the scene
off um and we're pushing against it and
pushing I'll try and I'll try and I'll
try and I'll say I'll just stop and I'll
say
I don't know if everybody agrees or not
but I just want to put something out
there we're we're pushing up against the
blocking in the scene we need to change
the blocking and then it's like a breath
of fresh air like everybody's like
[__] thank God like yes let's change
it and then we change it and then the
scene starts rocking you know and uh you
got to have guts to do that and I
learned from the best that you have to
have guts um some of my peers are
amazing at stuff like that and like
Ethan Hawk Ethan Ethan Ethan's in search
of the scene constantly and if you're
pushing up against it like he he says
right away no like let's just you know
like this is not right I've been in
scenes acting with him that he's done
that and he's been in scenes acting when
I've done it and I've he's been I've
been directed by him and so you have to
be there
but but no I stay very very calm even if
uh but but just before you know because
we've been on sets for a long time and
we know when thing when you're about to
roll like I get a sense immediately my
radar picks up I got five maybe 10
minutes here before we start real and
that's when I go in so the action
doesn't really mean anything to me I'm
already in by the time the director says
action I'm there so wherever I gotta be
I mean I can get ferocious on set like I
can be ferocious and loud and emotional
and like I don't give a [__] what people
think like honestly because you're
getting into it you don't give a [__] I
don't give a [__] uh whether it's crying
or Screaming or or laughing or whatever
the [__] it is you know crws are me are
taught not to put their hand in the cage
anyway I mean so the [__] you know and
and I love this man I love
it and I and I just I I just go um yeah
I go all the way so by the time action
is said I'm right when action I'm there
with dialogue boom I'm in like totally
it I love wow but I but most of the time
I spend on set is is calm and sociable
and and uh I'm just you
know passionate you're pass about the
homework you know it's about homework it
is if you do your homework if you put in
the time learn your lines and do your
homework figure out the scene know where
you were know where you are know where
you're going if you've done all your
[__] analysis of the story that
you're telling then you can show up at
work and have a great [__] time and
then when you know the camera is going
to start rolling you go where you need
to go you hear that actors do your
[__] homework me included sometimes I
haven't done my homework and uh well I
fail um you know
what I would have loved to have seen you
in Of Mice and
Men you you played Lenny
right I played him but not not where
anybody would see it yeah no back like
way back this was back in the day right
when you played in school but I kept
thinking of you like when I read that I
was like oh my God I'd love if he did
have a mice and men now like I love
malovic and you know why I never got the
chance to do it why because when I was
when I was the right age to play that
part it was a popular play they were
playing it everywhere and all the movie
stars were doing it and I I wasn't
enough of a name or to get that part on
a big venue ever and that's that's why I
never got a chance to play it which was
fine with me because I saw I went and
saw all the Productions of it and I saw
you know if it came back now would you
do it I'm too old to do it too old for
the part yeah because you had to be like
in your 30s right no when I was 30 and
that part was being played all the time
even it was even at Lincoln Center and
like it was like amazing Productions I
saw it even in England I used to do it
it was amazing wow I would just love the
chance to see you go um do I get to tend
to rabbits George I just [__] want to
see that man all right well I don't
think you're too old we did do it my um
in at the American stoski
Theater uh which is where I studied
perhap of my studies and then I was at
act then I was learned method acting
after that but with a woman named Sonia
Moore had a theater group and I
believe um I did the Play Somewhere In
Those Years along and during that time
and and it we were a little young for
the parts me and my friend Steve but we
we did it anyway what what makes you
laugh like who do you find funny as a
comedian or an actor that you're like
this this is funny this this guy makes
me laugh you mean in real life or in
their work it could be
both well Chris perhaps a funny [__]
guy I love that guy yeah I mean Dax and
I can make each other [__] laugh Dax
is funny as [__] you know and we have
the same kind of weird sense of humor
and it's it's very I find them hilarious
and and his wife uh Kristen just any you
know she just makes me [__] laugh
like crazy and they also send me they
stupid [__] all the time
two of them sitting you know before they
go to bed at night and they have this
idea about my life or something and
they'll send me this text they sorted
all out and they've even written stuff
out about my family tree and stuff it's
so [__]
funny if you uh have you ever heard his
wi Wilford
Brimley do I do I know who that was yeah
do you know that have you heard his
impression dax's impression of Wilford
Brin oh it's really in fact I just uh
hold on you know he played he played a
clip on me on his Jud Paul rut episode
so I'm going to [__] it's going to be
a record cold winter this year so when
your little ones come in cold from
building the Snowman warm them up with
an extra thick bowl of quak Oats it's
good it's
wholesome it's goddamn
American just ridiculous uh
this is awesome all right look I'm I'm
gonna quickly get in this is called [__]
talking with Vincent denafo this is my
top tier it's rapid fire so it's top
tier patrons I love you you guys support
the show thank you so much uh patron.com
inside of you uh Mike F what has been
the role that you found to be the most
fulfilling you said the first one pretty
much full metal jacket right yeah yeah
and then I would say uh the whole wide
world was uh was a at that time was the
most uh emotional Journey
Arc that I played in a character so so
that was fulfilling as well Lex says the
cell is one of the most underrated
psychological thrillers and Visually
stunning do you have any behind-
the-scenes stories or a favorite memory
from the filming you were't I
mean
terrifying people if you haven't seen
the
cell I I can't even describe it it just
goes to a place where you're like I
remember going like I felt like my body
was just it wasn't good Sam denoir
directed that and he's I've worked with
him twice um we also did a a a version
of Wizard of O called Emerald City for
NBC which was one season and uh it was
that just to work with him he's a
amazing visual artist and anyway so
um so he he wanted me to do that he
wanted me to play that that part and I
had just done like salt and sea and I
played some other kind of weird killer
guy and I was like you know I'd rather
just play some kind of normal dude and
and he he was like no you should really
think about doing this part and I'm like
yeah I don't I don't think I will it's
happened a couple of time in my career
and and the director convinces me and
how tar
samam I believe it was him that sent me
the
tape he was a commercial director he
hadn't done very much um stuff he did
the fall I think already which is a
whole other story I'll tell you about
someday but um how he actually made that
but anyway so he he sent me a commercial
emate so imagine you're looking down at
a blue tile floor you're about 20 feet
above the shot never moves it's just
composed perfectly all you see is blue
tile you're about 20 feet high camera
never moves never Zooms in nothing A guy
walks out in
robes tattered robes you know got it's
got that kind of Middle East kind of
feel just blue
tile carrying a bucket of water he walks
out so you're just looking down on him
as he walks out and he puts the bucket
to the right of the
center he walks back out he comes back
in pulling a goat by a rope walking a
goat
in he the coat walks to the middle of
the frame he drops the Rope he takes out
a [__] knife and cuts the Rope this
is all really happening in real life he
cuts the goat's throat the gro the the
goat Falls over the blood
comes out of the thing the guy picks up
the
bucket of water and goes like that and
washes the blood across the blue tile
the red blood and it says travel
Asia there's a
commercial
what and I'm like I called him and said
I'm in I'll do
it oh my God and it was a real goat [__]
yeah so you knew this guy's Vision was
GNA be actually shot it by the way there
on location in India like geez it's not
like he did he killed a goat for like a
movie he killed a goat because they
killed goats many goats a day oh my God
uh Stone AG how was your experience with
filming the Magnificent 7 rapid fire and
was there anyone in that amazing cast
who had never worked with before that
you really look forward to working with
again yeah yeah no like every one of
those guys were [__] brilliant
Denzel's amazing obviously he's like one
of the best oh yeah wait a minute I do
know that one yeah Chris is in that we
Chris and I then Ethan's in that I made
uh a really good friends with Manuel
rufo is now in Lincoln Lawyer stars in
Lincoln Lawyer he's he's amazing and
Martin sensire who's the most handsome
actor in the world he's this Native
American kid
who's his talent is growing and growing
growing he's gonna be a huge star I
think Martin it was uh so much fun it
was unbelievable
we had way too much fun to get paid
for like it was so much fun I love that
uh Kristen B last question my son Caleb
is a huge Jurassic World Fan what was it
like working with animatronic dinosaurs
in the movie any fun funny behind the
scenes stories you can share yes there
is so they had these guys walking around
in Le little leotards they were like a
little dinosaur dance troop yeah and so
there's a scene in uh in the and they
were very serious about it and I'm sure
very helpful but um there was a scene
where I had to get um sort of eaten and
one of the Raptors come in and kind of
pin me against this wall and I couldn't
do it with those guys I couldn't do it
with the little guys the little leard
guys did you yell at him get him out of
here get him out of here well I was just
like I was just like I can't like can
you just you have a dinosaur head you
can stick on
a
and um and they did and they put the
dinosaur head uh the same size as like
the
actual animalic Raptors and and yeah so
they put in the stick and I acted to the
guy to the head of so it was much easier
but I couldn't do the dance troop no do
it uh you do any
Impressions no not one
impression no I bet you could do a
really good it's different a lot
different but in the Cadence of a John
malovich I guarantee if you watching the
line of fire when when [__] Eastwood
goes you have a Rondevu with my [__]
[__] I guarantee if you watch
malovich go no what you couldn't
possibly know Frank and he does this
thing I guarantee you could [__] kill
it I'm not you're much too talented for
me I can't there's no way I could do you
don't do any
Impressions no you were never that that
guy growing up like memorizing quotes or
did you ever do that like what was your
favorite movie growing up um my favorite
movie you don't want to know my favorite
movie was willly
Wonka no actually it was a much more
deeper intense film than that it was um
Midnight Cowboy oh wow on Slinger film
great
film that's where he says I'm walking
here right yeah but um no I don't I'm
not that's not like that's not my I'm
not talented in that way I'm I'm barely
barely talented like I'm like right on
the French you have a children's book
you sing people I mean you're an actor
director producer you teach at strawberg
meth like you you do a lot of [__] man
but you can't do Impressions so I got
one on you bro yeah man I like the M
ofit you just did that was pretty
[__] good thanks man that I I like I
said I never left the house when I was a
kid so I do tons of Impressions and
that's what I you know that's kind of
yeah now I can I'm good
at doing like I'm good at producing you
you like I can change postures I can do
accents I can do all that stuff like I
can I can
create something that seemingly has
never been seen before seemingly because
it's all really it's all really
variations on variations on variations
but I can do stuff that
people think they've never seen before I
I always say you're one of my favorite
actors you're one of the nicest guys in
Hollywood I really believe I can't
believe you haven't yet but you're going
to win an Oscar someday whether you like
Awards or not I there's no I mean nobody
would be shocked if Vincent dafre wanton
a [__] Oscar be and the winner is oh
that's about [__] time well he hasn't
won one think I'm in a different
business than that I H I honestly don't
ever see that ever happening I just it's
no I just don't see it ever happening I
always have the same answer which is
this exact answer I'm telling you I just
don't feel like I'm part of that circle
like I have some amazing friends in this
business men and women that are
incredible artists and um you know uh I
just don't feel like you know that I'm
you know allowed into that Circle really
but I will say whether think you're part
of the circle or not I don't I never
thought I was part of any Circle I'm
like still the kid up in the [__]
room but I believe that sometimes you do
something and that leaves no choice for
those other people outside the circle
than to recognize something that
everybody obviously
recognizes so with that yeah it would be
a raise I'd get a bump in my pay if that
happened but also your career would go
downhill because once you win an Oscar
you know the story yeah and how boring
it's that like to actually get an award
for acting it's like really it's not
like not like Daytona 500an I want to
know where you would keep the award
though if you got an Oscar be honest
don't be like where would you keep that
Oscar it most likely would go somewhere
it wouldn't be out on the Shelf that's
for sure it would go in in the we call
it the [__] room bring on the [__] why
why would it be the [__] room what's the
[__] room it's just just a room in the
in the house where like all the crap is
in there it's like from Tarantino movie
like kind of thing like a it's just like
a like that's where all the nonsense it
stays it's not it's in boxes it's not
like a beautiful room it's like just
like there's like boxes of stuff every
once in a while my daughter will go in
there and straighten it up for me years
it's like it would go directly most
likely into today it's either that or
one of my sisters would grab it or
something all right well if you would an
an Oscar someday you got to promise me
to take a self you'll take a selfie
picture with it and send it to me I'll
take a selfie in the [__]
room in the [__] room with the Oscar
this has been awesome I'm not taking any
more of your time I love you this was
honestly incredible I love talking to
you hopefully you'll come on again I
hope it was easy and not bad it was so
easy dude thank you man thank you you're
you're Rock buddy thanks dude man I
appreciate it I'll see you later
man
legendary
man I mean that interview was just you
know sometimes I forget that I'm I'm
just like a fan sometimes I'm a fan now
I've gotten to G A little better so I
don't feel as much like a fan but like
initially when you meet someone that
you're enamored by or you love their
work it's kind of exciting it's like ah
you're a little nervous and um he can be
intimidating but he's also hilarious and
friendly and giving and um after
spending a few hours with him in Salt
Lake City City I just uh I really love
that kind F thanks so much for doing
this I appreciate hopefully it come back
and by the way any of the stuff I talked
about uh cameos and inside of you online
store and all that stuff you can go to
my Instagram at the Michael Rosen bomb
go in the link tree everything's there
so you can do that and don't
forget October 11th October 11 700 p.m.
or is it 8:00 p.m. I have a live podcast
inside of with Michael Rosen bomb is
live downtown Los Angeles at the Regent
Theater you can also go on my Instagram
at the Michael rosenbom the link tree
get tickets Zack Levi
Shazam Chuck the list goes on he is
going to be my guest it's going to be a
fun night get tickets there might still
be meet and greet tickets for the show
beforehand so do that all right without
these top tier patrons Ryan the show
wouldn't
be
we we love our patrons that is true
patreon.com inside of you become a
patron I'll write you a message and um
there's so many perks so many fun things
it's like a family become one let's do
it Nancy D lean Kristen little Lisa Yuko
Yuko Jill e Brian H H the camp Nico P
Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C always
got something to say that
uh Joshua D Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Ashley Ryan Mike E Elon
Supremo 99 more San Diego M Chad W
Leanne P Maddie s Belinda n Dave H
Sheila G Brad
d Ray H tabi the T Tom n Talia M Betsy D
Angel M ran and C Corey K Deb Nexon
Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joey M
Eugene and Leah I haven't seen you in a
while I want to see that kid Corey how
are you Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric
H Shane R Andrew M Amanda R Jan B J
Kevin e Stephanie K jorel jam and J
Leanne J Luna R Mike F Stone H Kayla
stay wild moonchild Brian L Kendall L
Caris C Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P
Kaylee J just talk to Kaylee Brian a
Ashley F Maran Louise L Romeo the band
Veronica Q Frank B Jen T Nikki L April R
Derek n jdw com bomb Ginger
Insomniac Rachel d lorai
l we love you thank you so much from the
Hollywood Hills and Hollywood California
I am Michael
rosenbom H Brian ta I'm here too right
is here we love you guys and uh thanks
for thanks for listening and um I
appreciate you be good to
[Music]
yourself